20 a321 coach qui en ont des projets il
ya des tournages et des choses qui se
passent il faut que tous les québécois
puissent se reconnaître tes joues des
films sentiment qui habite le plateau on
voit grand le cinéma québécois fait la
fierté de la province mais ce que le
cinéma québécois est vraiment québécois
ou plutôt montréalais en 2019 2020 il ya
84 % des projets en télévision ou au
cinéma
financé par la cdec qui était mort y
aller mais les choses pourraient bien
changer parce qu'ils semblent avoir tout
une effervescence autour du cinéma
région particulièrement esprits
le même des hommes l'industrie grâce au
financement participatif offert le tout
premier film comportant est strié et si
maintenant c'était à nous de faire notre
propre cinéma de produits ici même en
estrie des longs métrages de fiction
réalisé par nokia et surtout qui raconte
nostre ont fait demander est ce que
l'esprit pourrait devenir un joueur
important de l'industrie du cinéma au
québec
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en étant hautement
relativement la référente pour le cinéma
et la télévision au québec on sera
encore chanel outils et les commissaires
nationale pour le bureau cinéma et de la
télévision du québec
mon travail c'est de promouvoir le
cinéma d'ici et en tête en vue lui
demander c'est qu'est ce que ça prend
pour l industrie cinématographique
prospects
[Musique]
le bctq c'est s'occupe des
investissements étrangers
leur but c'est de démontrer tous les
attraits de la province de québec
des tournages à la post production
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que ça prend une industrie du
cinéma pour qu'elle soit prospère
ça prend ça prend tout et ça prend ça
prend la main d'oeuvre qualifiée ça
prend une main doivent aussi qui va se
développer en région en ce cas ci ça va
prendre des défis idiots donc la
capacité d'infrastructures en région ça
va prendre
la bonification régional un côté
gouvernemental fort qui appuient
justement le développement en région
puis dans ce cas-ci faciliterait
vraiment d'avoir divers tournages tant
pour la production locale que la
production étrangère donc mains des
bonifications milieu infrastructures
donc les studios puis puis bon après ça
c'est la vie est fixé de la post prod en
plus bel habit de l'équipement doit donc
dans la région ce soit c'est vraiment le
cocktail qui ferait en sorte que ça
fonctionne ça fonctionnait vraiment
[Musique]
le bctq usa tout le volet des
productions étrangères c'est souvent le
plus payant aussi parce que les grosses
productions qui viennent tourner au
québec
mais évidemment le cinéma québécois ce
téléfilm des créateurs d'ici
l'histoire était dans la cour de la
sodec la sodec la société de
développement des entreprises
culturelles du québec s'occupe du
rayonnement et du financement des films
dc obtenir de l'aide financière pour un
film c'est déjà difficile à montréal
alors imagine en région la très grande
majorité du financement serait dû aux
démos real
qu'est ce qui justifie que ce soit le la
très grande majorité des compagnies de
production indépendance sont situés à
montréal
il ya vraiment très peu de gros peine de
production qui sont établis en région un
chien pour accéder aux dépôts des gros
long métrage de fiction faut quand même
en avoir fait danse ou alors se comprend
bien moins de financement région parce
que les maisons de production sont moins
nombreuses mais aussi parce qu'elles
sont moins expérimentés
oui c'est ça le jour où il y aura une
masse crise et où les new york plusieurs
projets déposés en provenance des
régions
forcément mathématiquement on revoir
qu'il refuse de films de région d'un
parmi les 18 films maintenant qu'on
entre les mains toutes les informations
on retourne en estrie caisson voir si on
a tout ce qu'il faut pour développer une
industrie cinématographique forte
ouais
même si l'industrie est moins développée
en région on n'a pas non plus que des
maisons de production inexpérimentés en
2014 chasseurs film a quitté montréal
pour venir s'établir ici en estrie eux
ils sont convaincus que des films ça
peut se faire en région c'est un cercle
vicieux
thé dansant sous plus ça se passe à
montréal les gens m'ont s'installe à
montréal pour que savent pas fait vers
fin donc l'idée fait un petit peu de
dire comment on peut renverser ce cercle
club de faire en sorte que les gens
restent ici qu'ils puissent travailler
faire des projets ainsi que c'est plus
non plus possible aussi
technologiquement est ce qui n'était pas
le cas peut-être il ya 20 ou 30 ans en
estrie je pense que c'est un double défi
on ne réussit à mener des projets
destinés à ce montréalais à les amener
tourné en estrie il ya des longs
métrages d'un mix en binôme été un conte
humaine en estrie ski des superbes
ça permet à de la main d'oeuvre de
pouvoir exercer leur métier
mais son vrai dans un dynamisme ou
est-ce qu'on dépend projets de
production extérieure
c'est là qu'il ya des talents de
cinéaste garçon fait ici qu'il faut
encadrer
parce que ce sont ces gens là avec leurs
producteurs qui vont aller chercher de
l'argent qu'ils vont ramener des projets
ici notre film s'intitule des hommes et
nuit c'est une comédie dramatique qui
raconte l'histoire de trois personnages
sont un point tournant daury
connaissant les difficultés de
financement chasseurs fema décidé
d'utiliser le financement participatif
pour le premier long métrage d'un
réalisateur est strié admin triangle
cécile au long de la crise
si le défi qu'on a décidé de relever
avec jafar film de ben nous on va faire
en sorte que la première oeuvre donc le
premier long métrage des jantes allant
du s'ils vont être financés de manière
privée indépendante comme on a fait avec
la campagne pour les hommes après ça on
sait que leur talent en 2000 par exemple
est assez fort que une fois que ce film
là victor tiki barber sa signature ça va
être beaucoup plus facile d'aller
chercher du financement pour les
prochaines heures parmi les éléments
essentiels nommés par les experts du
cinéma qu'on a rencontrés il ya la main
d'oeuvre les installations et aussi les
lieux de tournage et c'est exactement le
mandat du nouveau bureau est strié de
l'audiovisuel et qu'ils utilisent
on sent venir rencontrer les gens du bim
dans leurs locaux qui sont situés dans
l'église du village de saint-adrien en
fait on est en train de rénover l'église
vont émettre des studios de post
production que si un plateau de tournage
on va voir si la console f6 il va avoir
un grand écran le en avant de chaque
côté voire de zèle mais notre mission en
fait c'est de favoriser la création de
contenus dans notre territoire
en fait depuis de mobiliser nos membres
pour créer ces contenus le puits pour
participer à la création s'effectue
aussi d'attirer des productions de
l'extérieur à venir utiliser nos
installations et nos talents le coup ici
en fait c'est l'espace multifonctionnel
donc au fond la borne reconstruire des
espaces de coworking plus deux autres
salles de montage ce qui est intéressant
quand on fait de la production en région
mais c'est d'avoir une main d'oeuvre qui
spécialisés qui connaissent le cinéma
leur note de ça avec le bingo si oui en
fait
c'est drôle parce que c'est tout ça est
arrivé quand par des expériences et ça
vient du vrai besoin d'une vraie
expérience on produise un vidéoclip pour
cargo qui est un artiste de singapour
connu internationalement qui est venu
faire un vidéo clip ici à saint-adrien
[Musique]
une journée on cherchait un assistant
caméra on trouvait pas on trouvait pas à
montréal personne est disponible dans le
coin ici on trouvait puis finalement le
nom qu'on s'est fait envoyer c'est un
monsieur qui habite dans un village de
saint-adrien à partir de ce moment là
mais je me suis dit si lui habite juste
à côté ici ça veut dire qu'il ya plein
de trésors cachés aussi dans la région
de l'estrie on s'est dit si on map
et puis on mobilise tous les gens qui
ont des compétences en caméra en vidéo
en audio tout ça on va être capable de
répondre aux besoins des producteurs
puis en plus on va être capable d'offrir
des emplois à ces gens là sur notre
territoire
puis l'homme aurait alors pu le monopole
de la culture puisqu'on réalisé qu'il y
en a pas mal finalement 2009 dans le
coin
oui il y en a beaucoup on est rendu au
dessus de 150 membres est un des
objectifs aussi c'est d'attirer beaucoup
de productions autant de montréal que de
l'étranger
ouais en fait une stratégie pour attirer
des gens à saint-adrien c'est ça passe
par la production d'un film sur v6 des
services pour le cinéma
nos décors et on peut faire facilement
la nouvelle angleterre avec des villages
comme richemont d'anneville tout seul
tout l'aspect post production le studio
de mixage 5.1 ici le grand studio les
salles de montage dans l'église tout ce
qu'on peut faire de a à z la production
la post production d'un film en estrie
le bingo pour objectif d'attirer les
productions étrangères
une façon de dynamiser l'industrie et
surtout donner de l'argent région le
bénir et 100 mais depuis 2013 un bureau
du cinéma sherbrooke qui a déjà attiré
quelques productions 2014
je voudrais que le premier le premier 6
mois 2014
et très riche en productions donc deux
productions étrangères qui sont venus
tourner ici
north pole un film pour la série a mais
bien une coproduction danemark québec
my sister's kid qui sont venus tourner à
lamine keïta facebook un grand discours
aujourd'hui de la série coin tiko qui
est débarqué sur le campus de
l'université de sherbrooke 2016
productions québécoises bon cop bad cop
2 qui a tourné sur le pont de ruches man
ray également à asbestos
2010 est une autre production québécoise
junior majeur je voudrais que les deux
dernières années ont peut-être est un
peu plus lente au niveau des productions
étrangères
quoi qui a des projets qui sont en liste
oui justement avec quels éléments se
distingue pour les productions
étrangères
les cantons de l'efs se distingue
beaucoup et sherbrooke se distingue
beaucoup par son architecture
l'architecturé anglo saxon qu'on ne
retrouve pas ailleurs que la proximité
également d affronter américain qui qui
peut aider beaucoup quand on parle de
productions étrangères
est-ce que vous pensez que l'estrie a le
potentiel de devenir un joueur
emblématique qu'elle est réel potentiel
de devenir tout ce qu'il leur ait suffit
d'avoir déjà affirmé convaincu qu'ils
ont le goût de briefer les variables oui
je pense que l'esprit peut devenir un
pôle important pour la production
cinématographique
je pense que ça va être plus dans la
collaboration entre toutes les régions
du québec qu'on va réussir à les
chercher des acteurs internationaux pour
ne travailler